here's how I would actually set out I'll
start by saying 1.6 meters is huge right
is really saying it's 1.6 times that big
box I was showing you before right the
big box that have event is up this high
and this way and this long right so if
1.6 of those boxes okay so therefore I
can say it's 1.6 times one cubic metre
okay now the reason I do that is because
now that I separated out the one cubic
metre okay just like over here I can now
do my conversion okay so I'm writing
this out a bit longer than you need to
but hopefully it makes the logic really
really clear this over here 1 meter
cubed is really one meter by one meter
by one meter yep
is that okay so fun yep yep ah see
there's the theme right no it's not
it's 1.6 cubic meters and each cube
meter is is one of these all right now
I'll give you an illustration of why
this should be different in a second
okay now let me do my conversion and
then I'll give you count written so each
meter is a hundred centimeters 100 100
100 by the way please don't skimp put
your units on there like this is the
whole point of the exercise so don't
just go from 1 1 1 to 100 100 100 the
reason why the numbers change is because
the units change with them ok and now
the last things left is to a value and
everything let's just do the numbers a
hundred by 100 by 100 that was a million
all right that's what we looked at
before okay this is 1.6 million that's
one six we have one two three four five
zeros after it
okay it's one point six movie I've got
my numbers and now I can
my units there are three lots of
centimetres being multiplied so I get
two centimetres commute okay and help
you understand why it's not 1.6 meters
times 1.6 meters times 0.6 meters just
put your pens down for a second and
imagine this river if I gave you a
different box you know hi I said to
imagine to imagine this box okay I want
you to imagine if we made the Box twice
the size along the width twice as high
so it's gonna go all the way up there
and twice as deep so it's going to go
twice as close to you now if we want to
draw such a look like this right it
still look like a cube but all of the
dimensions will be 2 meters 2 meters 2
meters now when we go to work out this
volume when we go to calculate this
volume I would say its height times
width times depth right its volume would
be 2 meters by 2 meters by it's 2 meters
right we'll just like up here onto my
numbers first and then I'll do my units
2 times 2 times 2 let's use it -
tostitos - yeah yeah it's gonna be too
huge like which is 8 right it's 8 and
then when you do meters meters meters
it'll be meters cube now hold on a
second hold on I said that all of the
sides were to meet it's right the two
meters and then they're okay but what
you end up with when you put the whole
thing together its volume is not 2 cubic
meters it's 8 cubic meters it's much
much bigger than that
right I'd be on a fit 8 million of my
cubes inside my little cute so therefore
when you're doing this conversion right
this is worth learning this is what not
to do right I'll put it up put it here
don't do this okay even though this is
1.6 meters cubed it's not 1.6 times 1.6
times 1.6 okay it's 1.6 of bees are
these 1 meter cubed boxes ok so that's
why I do this conversion and they all
become hundreds